hello welcome to see you're playing see
do nods and i am from turkey minus one
score what do we get yeah this this
opening is always slightly annoying this
line is it's very boring but not much
that you can do if they play it just a
passable line h6 is not strictly
necessary but I always feel that black
has some some leeway here what to do you
can pretty can play pretty much
everything and be okay the only issue is
that as I said it is rather boring
trying to be quickly I've got some
history against this guy he's so the
normal way it works is I have a good
position and then blunders stuff when I
have no time so I try to be quick and a
couple of Kings Indians for examples
against him for example against him when
I was basically just just winning out of
the opening but then still screwed up
with some stupid decisions ok so here he
cannot take because of that hanging
night that's a very equal looking
position I can move the Queen away I
mean you cannot take there in the first
place let alone ok maybe it goes to
three
yeah even if it takes to don't I don't
see him taking you five even I mean he
can but does it lead to anything
I just got this queen bee three ideas
maybe like takes takes Knight takes
Knight takes Knight takes Queen takes
Bishop h.323 but I've got g6
this one hmm okay is he threatening
something not not right now i think i
can give the exchange it's an
interesting idea not necessary i mean
that it's it's interesting can also play
we should be five for a simple move
let's let's give the exchange ideas rook
c8 possibly roots III or sometimes
specially 694 or something like that
yeah as usual I don't understand his
moves this is a typical thing in the
games that I had against him I have no
idea what he's doing we'll see 322 or
what's idea
parents that don't understand
you
ok so it just gives gifts the age three
Pawn okay I don't understand anything at
all I thought quinte to at least but
okay Queen h4 I guess on I mean I cannot
really avoid the trade things I can take
maybe taking a cesium Bishop takes I can
just take the pawn and Queen Texas miss
places the Queen again but I don't have
a super clear continuation I wonder if
g6 is a move to finally than King g7
check is not doing anything queen of for
every Queen f4 I am queen of course not
and it's got Queen III though doesn't
help ok let's do g6
for
I kind of very because of the earlier
games you know I had much better
positions like that against women in all
games and really all games and have
negative score some kind of extra
cautious
tix takes bishop see two to three time
morning almost promoting I can shake
yard check
and have no time I have no time why does
it happen against this guy of every game
I don't even know what I'm playing
against Queen d4 unfortunately
I hate this I hate this check from from
this kind of position yeah I'm getting
tricked with some stupid stuff check he
was totally outplayed of course but I'm
just too slow and making stupid mistakes
check check black resigns I don't know I
don't know I don't know what's happening
here in this game against him so Jen you
just completely useless it just gave me
that point no reason and now I just have
to win the game but I fail I really fail
okay but should be five is the first one
but that should also win the position is
just so much better for black two pawns
he's got no no King position and
everything so ok this is this ok Bishop
f5 is a mistake Queenie one wins check
that was because of Bishop c6 of caution
hmm yeah I don't know ok i'm just-just
attacking ships e6 and so on it's got no
play yeah this is amazing I was
originally thinking this would work but
he gets owned and behind the porn it
even wins check so this is it should
still be ok but this is probably not
working Queen D foil so this is this i
can play you know like it's through
better but
I'm already making things far more
difficult and yeah I'm losing I don't
know I always have problems against
people who have a bad score again so I
have bad kind of memories yeah I'm kind
of I think I'm playing badly then for
some reason it gets worse it's a bit
like yeah I don't know check always have
a bad kind of mindset down and then I'm
playing extra stupid children wait you
did everything to lose really I mean
especially white we need to you can just
go here right what is the problem ok
cantik with this it's also bad about the
whole kind of setup is so this is bad so
allowing the exchange sacrifice is
already a weird decision we can just
take the five and have a pill have a
normal kind of game Queen takes I guess
Bishop takes and something is equal I
mean he should be okay with being equal
you hear this is just already a bit
awkward for white to play yeah anyway
thanks for watching